with the taliban sweeping to power in
afghanistan countries around the world
including the united states are
scrambling to form coherent foreign
policies to deal with the new regime but
it is the restive nations neighbors and
near neighbors who will need to adjust
most quickly to what comes next
for most this new awkward reality poses
great risk but perhaps also some
opportunity
china worries taliban controlled
territory could be used to harbor
separatists and be a destabilizing force
in its western xinjiang region but it's
likely to take a pragmatic approach
helped by the fact that unlike russia in
the united states it's never invaded its
number one priority then will be for
stability and the management of threats
and then to play a greater economic role
perhaps as part of a political
settlement
russia of course knows what humiliation
in afghanistan feels like with the
soviets leaving an unwinnable war in
1989 moscow now will be nervous about
security in the country and will not
want it to turn into a haven for
terrorists in 2000 chechen separatists
trained in the country moscow doesn't
trust the taliban but the kremlin
understands the dynamic of real politic
they'll be keeping their embassy open in
kabul and will want to remain the
dominant power in central asia
but perhaps more than all the others it
will be pakistan that watches and tries
to influence most closely it's widely
claimed it helped create the taliban
prior to its 1996 takeover pakistan's
military and its intelligence agency has
long seen an ideologically similar
afghanistan as a buffer against its
perpetual rival india and the fear of
encirclement but there is significant
danger of blowback a possible refugee
crisis on its border and the
empowerments of islamic militants inside
the country
iran is also facing a huge influx of
refugees it's already estimated that it
hosts more than three quarters of a
million afghans tehran is hoping the new
rulers will be different from their
previous incarnation and the iranian
leadership will try to have and exert
influence which will almost certainly
lead to its cooperation with the taliban
afghanistan's new leaders certainly at
the moment are seeking to gain
international recognition most states
are still trying to work out how to
respond
but what happens next will once again
not be decided only by those inside the
country
outside actors as they have all too
often in the past in what could come to
be known as the new great game will also
be shaping afghanistan's future